who wants to watch Brad Wright and
Richard deine Anderson talking about the
classic episodes Children of the Gods I
do I do well you lucky bunnies you can
too thanks to our friends at the
companion who are celebrating the
beginning of a new series of Stargate
Legacy with Brad Wright starting just
this Sunday where they're going to be
talking about pretty much everybody's
top three favorite episode window of
opportunity we have been allowed to
share with you last Year's 25th
anniversary episode where they talked
about children of the Gods so please go
and check out the link in the
description for the upcoming event but
also sit back and enjoy Richard Dean
Anderson and Brad Wright talking about
the first two episodes of Stargate sg1
the episodes that began it all the
episodes that once they took the boobs
out anyway was an instant classic
episodes that I immed immediately fell
in love with welcome to Sid Trek your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and our
friends over at the
[Music]
companion
let's bring in the man who helped make
all of this happen Brad Wright and the
star of stars Richard Dean
Anderson hey Lawrence how you doing star
of stars yeah there's stars and then
there's you at the top it's a Christmas
star
yeah Brad's a naturally sunburn me I get
embarrassed so
okay well that's what we're here for
yeah to celebrate you and embarrass you
a little bit because you've really
changed so many so many lives I think in
the comments and everyone has been
talking about it um all day let's not
launch this conversation on that subject
okay deepers no it's the 25th
anniversary it's just fun it's just fun
25 geez that's for the ser
right that's for that's for the premiere
of sg1 which was 25 years ago today I
mean we it's for us it's like longer
because you know we shot it for a lot
longer than a lot long before it aired
so yeah no it's longer for
us doesn't look like it sometimes for us
movie people yes I've been at this we
started writing it 26 years
ago pretty much must be very
tired sorry old
joke I think I wrote it for you um yeah
just we're gonna tell hopefully some
good stories but if it's hard to come up
with some what we've done is we found
some old photos some behind the scenes
images um we cated some fan stories as
well uh just as kind of thought starters
for you both and and hopefully let you
know and show you how much the entire
Community cares so uh yeah why we kind
of show the first photo it's of a young
Brad um and oh my God I don't know if
Rick you can oh yeah if you remember
Brad at that kind of age that young Brad
oh
Jesus uh yeah that's a young Brad um it
was hard to tell oh yeah how I was uh
this is season one I was 30 oh I can
tell from the computer I was 36 35 or
36 yeah look at that computer
yeah yeah you're beautiful bud you
haven't changed a bit well I still have
hair that's you know that's a plus yeah
yeah we also have another photo as well
it's with uh I guess Rick and and maybe
the questions um you know as a man of
action maybe you could describe I don't
know if you ever did like what's it like
either doing the stunts or watching some
of the stuntmen I guess be you and doing
since I don't know if you have any
stories there or Brad if you remember I
remember this one times yeah this this
one had a lot of wire
work we actually there's a my favorite
one of my favorite shots in the show is
is the very end with the spinning we
turn the the puddle into the spinning
Vortex because of the gravity that
because was we actually accidentally
dial the black hole and so that is uh
O'Neal
and's
the no that's a
guy uh was it Colonel Frank yeah it's
Colonel something yeah I'm G forget his
name and they were uh they didn't like
each other they were they were at odds
over a previous off they worked on
together and and uh he sacrifices
himself in the last scene it's spiler
alert
uh but yeah that was a fun that was a
fun uh that was a fun
shoot might be that
blurry person might be might be you Rick
right there is that aren't those stunt
people or what what they stunt
people I don't know I can't tell I can't
yeah yeah no I mean they're so tiny you
did it too you did some artwork I
remember I
remember yeah it was quite athletic
actually because the shot of having to
reach back up you would have uh yeah
that would have been quite a lot of cor
work it was good it was good no it's not
me it was a way
too it was a ways too fun
times we
got yeah uh season two yeah yeah uh we
have another fun photo I don't know if
uh you guys seen it but I've never seen
anything like this obviously you know
you imagine these pyramid htech uh
spaceships being you know so huge and
obviously the special effects are
groundbreaking you know for its time and
you know as an actor I'm sure you're
seeing these tiny you know wheeled out
pyramids on a on a on a wheelie bin in
the parking lot and and we see it on
screen um just you know massive I never
knew that those were that size I thought
they were all just generated but uh no I
know what this one was
for uh Rob Cooper this might be from the
200th episode Rob Cooper wanted to blow
up a pyramid like just massive explosion
and
Ry uh did it and we built a this giant
thing buil it full of explosives and
blew the [__] out of it to do an
explosion you back in the day at least
you needed uh you needed significantly
you couldn't just do it all CG you had
to have a real explosion and comp it all
together so and and Rob wanted a big
explosion we spent a fortune on that
shot
actually yeah because these days it
would just be like visual effects right
in CGI it wouldn't it was a combination
yeah back in the day was mainly a
combination right I'm more impressed
with the sky that's that that's a
Vancouver Sky if I ever saw
one
Beauty yeah
rain and uh we've got another photo as
well um it's of you Rick walking
down the Vancouver sulfur pits uh I can
only imagine the smell I don't know if
you remember at all and I hope actually
you don't remember what this actually I
don't remember it being stinky like
sulfur can
be it it wasn't uh it wasn't smelling it
did rot everybody's shoes but um
okay uh and you could like later sorry
you could light your
feet yeah so Brad you you would go down
to these locations as well um or like in
the beginning would you do that or how
that early on well of course uh early on
um what we were doing was trying to come
up
with something that wasn't running
around in
trees that because that's what we had
right we couldn't we couldn't build
much and if we wanted to be outside you
know it was either
trees or something like this and there
was
a and I you know nobody would let us do
this
now what for good reason probably but it
looked great I mean the the the perfect
blue sky and cont
to the it's sort of a Ukrainian flag not
I think of it but uh uh the the I mean
it was just it was just terrific and
then Richard H Doolan our production
designer put um put crystals in it and
the crystals drove the story
and then Rick got to play two different
o'neals alien O'Neal and
him is that Lazarus yeah called
Lazarus I don't I don't understand why
Jeff Jeff King who wrote the episode I
don't know why he named it that may not
he just went
okay but uh coers all right sounds okay
um there's another funny story about
that episode and that is uh and this is
true
story uh at the end of that episode it
is it really is at the end um there's a
great scene with Harley Jen kak as as uh
O'Neal's wife and they have a moment
together and and we shot it in a
hospital and they had this moment
together and and it's a really kind of a
touching scene where he's basically
saying goodbye to her because he needs
to move on because of the we were trying
to shed the backstory from the feature
where O'Neal had accidentally left a gun
in a place where his son could find it
use it and kill himself which by the way
made him a pretty shitty Soldier so um
we wanted to kind of move beyond that so
that Rick could be untethered by you
know the previous character and so he
wrote this lovely or Jeff and I wrote
this
lovely um goodbye scene between the two
of them and and in editing we put this
we wanted a moment to last a little bit
longer as they're staring at each other
and and we made it last as long as we
could editorially and then we put in the
sound of a helicopter coming so they're
looking at each other they're looking at
each other then they
hear and then O'Neal says I got to go
and she says I know beautiful moment
touching moment this is the note I won't
say who I got from either the network or
the studio I don't remember
which uh Brad can we see them getting
into the
helicopter and I
said sure oh right we had a helicopter
there we just didn't we just didn't
shoot it we we just cut the helicopter
out and he went well I heard a
helicopter and I said yes you heard it
it was a sound
effect real note real note I couldn't
believe it
anyway that's my memory of that episode
that's the thing that that stuck that
Network note who was that that was I'll
tell later no no it wasn't it was not H
not
John no no no John just went good
episode Bradley that's what he that's
that's all John would
say is he still with us I think so I I I
haven't spoken to him in oh God five or
six years maybe longer but yeah he's
doing okay he's retired I think yeah
we're talking about John Sims um who I
the man who brought us together right
and who I kind of almost uh owe my
career
to yeah was at Paramount before uh
before
MGM yeah good guy hey I I owe my career
that's for sure he was he was very very
good to
me I don't fans we don't want to start
talking about old Executives that we had
affairs with or really there was no
Affairs no M well you know in the
majority yeah what does pajora
mean not good p or really yeah
yeah look that
up means not good oh yeah this is also a
famous location um Jack's cabin not in
Minnesota but in Vancouver know there's
any fond memories here
or do you ever go out to hear
Brad Yeah Yeah we actually shot an
episode of Travelers there recently well
few years ago it's it's the footprint of
that place is not very big like I mean
it looks like it's out in the wilderness
it is not if you p a little this way
it's isn't there a road right there
there's a road right there
yeah are there any it looks good
though has a comfortable day of
shooting yeah with lots of fish okay
apparently it's quite a famous location
there's there's been quite a few films
and shows kind of all shot like at this
this location I don't know if it's like
a popular production very tiny
inside it's very convenient to get there
and yeah especially from
bnab nice and then we also have a photo
uh I think we talked about this last
time but you know it's I'm I'm sure
this's a really special moment uh being
honored by the Air Force and um
yeah that's you that's a jumper Rick
yeah General jumper yeah that's him
y yeah oh
yeah that was actually quite um moving
for me
because my uh ongoing relationship with
the military in general no individuals
or specifics but in as as a
concept I
well let's put it this way I I wasn't
trying real hard to get into the Vietnam
War um and it kind of started there but
these guys just opened up
their well in this case uh General
jumper uh took me aside and chatted me
up and uh gave me all kinds of Kudos
because I had asked him directly at one
point um you know please forgive me if
uh if it is so but um do you have other
um Colonels in the uh in the Air Force
who are like Jack O'Neal and he stopped
me in mids sentence and said yes and
worse I I didn't know how you could get
worse he said yeah the Ed The Edge on
the attitude would probably have to be
altered a little bit but uh no you're
doing a great job son
when you save the world as many times as
Jack O'Neal
did I think you get a little attitude
you know little latitude world saving
latitude just check another one if the
world only knew but that was really a
great
event uh I forget there was also someone
retiring uh during the ceremony not
because the ceremony wasn't just for me
it was U kind of accumulation and there
was somebody of great great um
honorability that was being
um honored as
well is that Tom Gazo in the
background are one of our no I don't
think so it it seemed well I don't know
it could have been I'd be unaware of it
but it was all military that I mean it
was a big Auditorium and
he was our he was our Air Force liazon
so he was military but I don't I
can't he certainly positioned himself
properly find the
camera yeah good
job so this was um like a big um like
Air Force event not not like
specifically for Stargate or anything
this is a uh like you you sort of joined
um as part of this kind of Air Force
event or celebration right
Rick well yeah I would I I can't imagine
that they would have thrown the whole
thing for me but I quite honestly think
it was
uh um it was for hang I wish I could
remember his name but he was uh in a
wheelchair and you know was he'd been
around quite a while so they were
honoring him oh let's put it this way I
went first so that meant you know the
big gun came out later so but they were
honoring you and I think that was great
I thought that was great they were
honoring yeah
yeah and he was the only the he was the
first general who did a cameo in
Stargate the the and who was the second
guy jeez so
bad uh but he said one of the first
things he said once he took over the job
was of general of the Air Force
apparently allegedly was when do I get
to do my Stargate
Cameo and we said they told they said
that to us and he said whenever he wants
to so they did
yeah well you know all those guys and
I've met a few I've met a few generals
and I met an admiral you never got to
meet the Admiral because I was he and I
were on the plane to go to the Arctic it
didn't make
because of the wind shear we couldn't
land and he was the Admiral in charge of
uh the operation on on the ice that
allowed you to be in the Arctic and see
the sub come through the ice and
continue him but anyway he was a really
cool guy too they're all they're all I
mean when you get to a high level in
that in any organization but especially
the military the the the social skills
are just like through the roof you know
they're he very good with people
yeah we got some um fan photos that um
or fan stories actually that um kind of
show the legacy of star I don't know if
you have heard or seen any of these
stories before um so this one is from
Quinton and brazza they're two members
of a fan group called L de mcgyver which
is I guess literally directly for for
Rick here the children of
mcgyver um and they came up with this
idea to create a 100% accurate and fully
functioning
Stargate um I don't know if you you've
heard this story or or I don't know if I
have yeah SE yeah fully functioning as
the prop not necessarily yeah working
star let's be clear oh I bought it I
bought into it yeah uh I don't know if
we can go back to the last photo Tom but
um the last one was kind of showing reys
when the project first started he was
only 13 years old um and the project
eventually took eight years to complete
and so he was one of the 100 people um
in total on the team eight different
countries four different languages they
had to um communicate through texting
and email and images rather because they
couldn't speak to each other necessarily
uh and So eventually rest joined the
team and um uh and for his like college
uh thesis project at the Royal Central
School of speech and drama he he
actually used this as one of his kind of
thesis final
projects um yeah so I mean that's how
long and dedicated these fans were um
yeah so then the next image yeah that's
him here yeah Reese um and so the three
of them to kind of give you a scale um
and I guess it's actually as how how big
the Stargate
Atlantis
um you know gate was yeah that's the
Atlantis gate that that that first photo
was a really good photograph as a
photograph thanks yeah we went down and
and captured them when they were uh this
was actually three years ago I think
when we we captured some of these uh for
these guys and
so so yeah this is like you know the I
have to say the sg1 gate was more
complicated the the Atlantis gate uh
turned just digitally it didn't there
was not a physical wheel that moved not
like our our uh cheaters our sg1 G that
was a pretty cool
prop yeah really
yeah um yeah this is the the kind of
excitement and passion um you know that
starget I guess brings out to the fans
you know I'm sure they didn't think it
was going to take eight years um but you
know keeping a 100 people motivated I
guess for nearly a
decade with just passion there was you
know there wasn't anything else
is it's it's uh I mean the the thing
about this show is is that the gate
itself is such a powerful icon and and
that's why we changed it for each
iteration of the show to Brand the gate
to the show but even even changing from
the movie because the there was no it
didn't light up uh in the movie we had
ours light up because we knew it was
probably going to be on a 20in or less
television set in standard definition we
wanted it to pop on the
screen um and that's that's how long ago
25 years
is jez you know I mean standard
de at least we had the sense to transfer
transition into
color the black and white dos were
just yeah although the Noir they were
good for the Noir episodes it really
worked well for
those
sorry got me got me sorry bud no good C
love
it no we uh I remember when they when we
saw the Stargate the original sg1
Stargate as they were building it
because why did I know let's we were
like yeah build a state and and it was
the massive undertaking and you know all
the you the original one and and uh
setting it up and and and making it work
and I remember seeing it work for the
first time and I think we were both
there Rick it was like holy [__] because
it was huge it was a big I mean it was
the same scill as in the fature we
wanted it to be that but Jonathan and I
went because we thought well maybe there
maybe the existing Stargate exists and
and we found out I was in LA um I don't
know if it was around casting but anyway
I was in LA working with John on on on
on the pilot episode I think and we
drove out to to where the Stargate was
being stored I think it was like in
Death Valley at least it felt like Death
Valley because it was over 100 degrees
Fahrenheit and we walked out and and and
there was just this piece of Arc Steel I
mean that was all that was left
everything that was attached to it
everything that made it a Stargate was
worn Away by the weather and I remember
stepping into it and looking up and
seeing a giant spider coming down toward
me on a web thought oh I should put that
in an episode we never
did but yeah the movie one uh died in
the
desert it really
did it did but the the dimensions were
the same I think so yeah in fact we had
the blueprints and then that really
helped us build it um we they
they locked every Chevron as it went
around and what we did is we just locked
the top one so that because it was
really expensive to make that thing go
Jun
Jun uh so we just did the
top and made the dialing that much
longer but sometimes that was a good you
know 20 seconds of screen time that we
could use with Gary saying Chevron one
encoded and then would spin again Shevon
2 encoded and every time you type that
in a script you'd be like okay there's
another 30 seconds that's great
if you had it paded out we of added more
Chevrons
yeah is that why every generation like
eventually get to universe and there's
just you know eventually you're going to
get to like 10 or 12 Chevron you could
just keep
going in my uh in my pilot script that I
I uh I uh I wrote that'll probably never
see the light of day uh a couple years
ago when MGM asked me to write a pilot
script the um for a new show uh I had an
entirely new human built Stargate and it
just
went spun up like crazy and then went
just and open because I thought it's
about time we sped up the process after
25 years don't you
think so uh yeah maybe they'll do that
anyway it's cool it was really cool at
least in the script yeah what what made
you go digital in Atlantis versus uh the
kind of more manual I I I think it was
uh what are you doing R am I moving
around yeah I'm just looking at your
hand yeah you're just uh like you're
kind of finger um no uh the uh I thought
you were changing the channel that's
really all I thought you there's
something else on Brad's talking too
much no I was trying to adjust my eyelin
so I could look at you and still see me
ah good
what the hell was I saying Lauren uh I
was asking in Atlantis why why you went
digital from the M uh it was just uh
digital everything was going digital uh
so we went digital too and um we wanted
it to look different and I and that was
by no means my idea I think the only
idea I had is I wanted the chevron color
to be different and not not this sg1
Chon color but it's beautiful and the
SGU um one is is I think beautiful too
and and uh and that was James Robbins
who designed that that was gorgeous
thing when you when you think about that
then you're you're not giving like a
really solid brief you're giving it to
the art Department you're giving it to
an art director to come up with
something or do you have actually well
the way the process works is is you know
they you write the script that's your
job and then you have a meeting in an
art department and they show you [__]
and they go what do you think of this
and I go and I back in the day I go this
is really good and and if it was a big
enough thing I'd go down to the set of
the trailer and run into Michael
Greenberg and Rick who were sitting at
the at you know you know video Village
and I'd show them a piece of paper and
I'd say what do you think of this and
they'd go either cool or I don't know
let's let's do something else and uh but
generally speaking our art departments
were astoundingly good from from the
get-go I mean Richie toolan bridg
McGuire James Robbins they just were
terrific and worked so hard I mean I
used to think I was coming in early
sometimes and there would there half the
art Department would already be there
and you know the sun isn't even up yet
and they're they're there you know it's
astounding that's how hard people work
in this business yeah Rick did you ever
give Brad any notes at
all I whed a couple of times but not
seriously no I had sense enough to stay
out of the way pretty much um was kind
of part of my
job and that's all I'm gonna say about
that I mean the whole thing was
collaborative but um the main stay was
right on your screen
there your screen there there okay well
it was and I can't take all the credit
either not in a millionair Rob Cooper uh
was uh amazing and uh and John
got the ball rolling and we had we you
know we had a great
team Paul and Joe Paul Paul moly
jotti Joe is probably leading the Tweet
storm right now for trying to get
Stargate back on the on the on the air
in some capacity wait this Stargate or
any another one another one this one is
already on air somewhere I'm sure uh
it's it's uh always playing somewhere
which is wonderful thing there's nothing
better than flipping through channels
and oh they Stargate oh yeah and it's
invariably an episode I can't stand and
I have to turn
it star star for me why it have to be
that
one Stargate for me it's like um there's
a type of movie or a show where I call
it like come on for the ride type show
and like it doesn't really matter where
it's at Back to the Future is very
similar like you can go halfway through
a Stargate episode you actually stumble
on to it and you go okay like I'll watch
this for like 5 minutes and it just
takes you on the ride and then before
you know it it's the end of the episode
so you could be at the beginning you
could be the middle you could be three
quarters the way through but it it's
that kind of show for me you know where
it's just on and then and then you
forget what you were watching before or
doing
before sometimes sometimes it's on and
I'll go holy [__] we did that we
submerged this the set in a pool made
actors dive in the cool actually that's
the kind of thing that Rick went hell
yeah I'll do that I'd love to do that
Lov you
did awes and then uh then there's the
ones that you go there we are running
through the trees
again only to
myself um the whole experience of course
in retrospect was spectacular it was a
turning point in my life I mean
objectively speaking it mcgyver was
launched me into an awareness of the
whole business the whole She Bang uh but
this um this series really kind of the
collaboration of it for one thing they
allowed me to um be kind of involved in
the development part of it but not so
much
really um I I just knew a good good
thing when I saw it and relaxed into it
as much as I could and again tried to
stay out of the way these guys knew what
they were doing good
Lord did you when you first heard about
you know the script and the concept and
everything Rick did you think it would
actually like become what it became I
mean you know eventually 17 seasons of
you know this this ongoing long massive
Universe of a story
no you can't afford to think that way
just kind of have to do it unless you
can sign a I knew this thing had been
what to Showtime was it right yeah
showtime for two seasons out of the gate
is that correct that's right yeah so we
knew that it at least had you know two
seasons worth of uh to get the momentum
going and it took I you know I I don't
know how that part of it works but uh
you know
some um some Executives thought it was a
good idea and Brad and
Jonathan had um had the energy and the
wherewithal and the imagination to take
it forward
so just
aot yeah I remember I just do remember
thinking well if they want
um Kurt Russell in this role they're not
gonna get it
um and I've been quoted as saying in the
past that my hair just wouldn't do
that it's true you said that on the
phone to me I remember that very very
clearly and then I and and then and then
I said jokingly I said and this is where
that started I said and and I didn't
even know it was because we misspelled
the original one and I said you're not
that jackon
you're your jack O'Neal is spelled with
two L's you're a different guy and we
laughed and I was that but it it it
became a runner in the show I mean he
did the two L's joke more than once
holding up three fingers of course
because it's Rick and uh and you know it
was this Runner but there was a time and
we've discussed this uh when when kurk
came to
set yeah and he was lovely and said oh
this is this is a you know this is a
really cool show and and walked into our
Giant and said this is this is as good
as ours this is amazing and was lovely
to Rick and I wanted to ask him to to to
be in the show and have him stepping out
of the elevator saying hi Jack and and
Rick going in saying hi Jack but no that
was never gonna happen mainly because uh
uh the movie he was doing was graceand
and he looked like Elvis yes and just
gonna say it's perfect all lost
opportunities it would have been fun it
would have been a lot of
fun um would have helped his career
too I think he's doing okay I love him
as Santa by the way I mean he's like the
best
Santa if you haven't seen it Rick it's
it's a great Christmas movie he and uh
especially in the in the second one uh
Goldie hon plays who was his his partner
plays Mrs Santa Mrs Claus and they are
hilarious together as Santa I mean he's
really fun they got
married I know they're are they married
now I don't know I think they they went
through the ceremony yeah oh
cool we don't talk so I don't
know um over lockdown a lot of people
either discovered Stargate for the first
time or rediscovered it um since their
childhood um and I know a lot of people
connected over that um and so we have a
short video
that a group of PE um a group of ladies
came together they found each other on
Tik Tok through Stargate and uh and
bonded over so they made a short video
uh that I want to show you as
well hello I'm Sarah I'm from
Pennsylvania and I am the O'Neal of the
group hi I am Christina from California
and I aspire to be the Daniel of the
group hi I'm Rebecca I am from South
Carolina and and I am the Sam Carter of
the group and we're free fries short
free fries
short Stargate yes so we host the
Stargate podcast brought to you courtesy
of our love for the show and we met on
Tik Tok and the Phantom was alive and
well Stargate was something I always
grew up with I watched it with my dad
and I've always come back to it
rewatched it throughout my youth and
adulthood and when Co hit I was was like
it came back and it came back stronger
than ever because now there's a whole
community of people that I can talk
about a show that's turning 25 years old
and we can still find something new and
exciting about it every time we talk
about an episode I joined um Tik Tok
just to get through coid but ended up
finding my family and my authentic self
through Stargate I'm super happy um to
have found these ladies and be in a
podcast for them yeah I if the question
is what impact has Stargate had on me um
it's right here it's that I have a a
whole family now not to mention our
notorious tattoos that exist the place
gosh we're like a gang a g we're a gang
I think that's the power of fandom it's
it's a television show that's put out
there and people can connect and bond
and and have discourse and maybe you
don't always agree but you can connect
with other people who are across the
country and I've never met in real life
yet and the world
thank you for that Stargate and I think
we can all say happy birthday yeah happy
birthday okay bye
bye oh
my that's lovely it is
lovely that's
wonderful and nice
personalities
cheapers yeah hire them I I have to
listen to that podcast now yeah yeah
they're really they're really great um
oh they would love you on their podcast
well I'll I'll we'll chat afterwards
I'll fire your note Brad okay yeah hook
me
up that's great I know I love it yeah
they're really great and uh yeah really
they're watching right now I'm I
hopefully they're very excited and and
you know in the Pod they're very
supportive of us as well and and help us
out all the time they're really really
great gals really cool terrific
wonderful girl um oh gender thing is
that girls is
okay it is okay I've checked with them
um pronouns yeah yeah I have they're
absolutely lovely but I want to be
linked in to that too yeah oh yeah they
would love it yeah um here's another
thing about let's say uh Stargate and
culture and Society and and affecting
things it's kind of a fun thing but um I
don't know if Rick you've ever had in
your contract like if they ever put out
merchandise like say action figures we
found some like action figures of you
did you ever get any of these or have
you ever seen these action figures I
think one we have is like Black Ops
O'Neal we've got another one um uh is
like uh I guess you're in like a desert
oh it's not this one it's
uh one H sorry yeah one here
yeah
I I don't know that
$150 yeah that's what it would cost
right now on eBay if you want to go and
bid for
yourself I don't think that's the
original sale
price oh yeah no no this is the
collector price yes good Lord Increase
five times in value 10 times in value I
guess it's they should really do action
figures of writers typing I think I
think that would be really cool the the
jalas maybe not they would sell for you
know
less yeah um and then yeah I mean it's
uhh there's a the kind of uh Tom I kind
of messed you up because I think I went
out of order um but there's board games
as well and so the previous photo um um
if you are able to go back um they I
guess MGM uh in a company called wyvern
gaming they started doing this role
playing game was very successful uh with
a crowdfunding campaign and people can
be a Stargate command Stargate team you
know inspired by you you know and the
rest of the cast and you know they go
out on their own adventures and and with
this kind of role playing game you you
assume a you're you become a member of
Stargate command basically and so and
you get to walk in a nice dress through
the Stargate
yeah
they are
unprepared form fitting nice no but they
you know and then there's the guy who's
doing what Rick always used to do with
the puddle like draw in it and we would
just go okay that just cost that just
cost
$4,000 oh well I think it's a good I
think I was doing mine you know
[Laughter]
oh of course you would that's funny um
and then um and then after no shoes on
that guy either it's like just
big he doesn't need shoes that Fe
robust
yeah um and then if you Tom if you go um
kind of uh Farther Along two more sorry
I messed you up yeah I played a trading
card game of yourself Rick but um that's
what this looks like they were they made
trading cards as well um really
yeah
yeah this goes way
back yeah I think this was produced
around 2007 or 2008 I think from memory
U we were still shooting I remember I
remember getting a because there was
also special cards that were signed by
the actors and you could you could get a
special sign
card it was
cool yeah those those go for a lot now
online as well with the actual
figure yeah wonder if my lawyer should
be looking into
this Rick havea me and we'll we'll hook
it up the piece was so small you didn't
notice
it oh I don't know I'll talk to
Bill how is he
doing very well very well good
yeah all I always end up I I happen to
talk to him over the years a few times
in my efforts to get you to come back
and
play uh in other
shows I never heard about well that's
because I asked you first and you said
sure and that but then I also had to
talk to go oh right I forgot I I
couldn't just say you're working for the
craft service because you would have
said oh
cool is it salmon
perfect oh the days oh the days um Rick
ate a piece of
salmon and maybe a little bit of rice
every day I don't know almost every day
wouldn't you say Rick for lunch um
because you you were keeping your spell
action figure uh form I don't know if I
was paying that much attention later
on
okay as evidenced by what you see today
no you look good you look really
good for an old guy maybe yeah I didn't
say that part that was implied I
know for the so they know how we think
between each yeah that's right that's
right not that far behind you new
card new
card you power up to four four
now um we have one last I'm sure would
be a collector's item but is hidden away
in I believe Brad's server room bunker
oh
you look
um so so handsome
and here here's what here's what here's
what James did we did an episode this is
from SGU we did an episode set in the
Pentagon and so we had to have artwork
of people and rather than you we can't
would be better to use people but then
you have to get the rights to use
somebody's face so I remember walking
down out of my he said Brad could you
step out here for a second and I did and
I gave him that look apparently and he
took my picture and walked away and I
went what H was that about then as I
often did on on the SGU I would I walked
the set before they started shooting and
I'm walking down the hall I think I
can't remember who directed that episode
possibly Peter
Del and we uh I look at the end of the
hall and there's that that picture of me
and that is an enormous picture by the
way like it's it's you know as it's as
tall as I am in real in real life and I
just went no
no that's not going to work and then
there was supposed to be a damaged area
so we just put that picture in the
damaged area where you couldn't really
see it it's a great shot it's a great
shot it just felt
very what my shoulders have not that
white it's it's a it's just very self
aggrandizing in my to feature it in the
show would have felt self-aggrandizing
to me so no why it's not in your home is
what I want to know that is my home it's
just a
closet yeah oh that's
where
fireplace that would go really well with
my wife senal Brad over the fireplace I
don't think so no it's really good it's
it's fun I mean that's how good James is
right he just takes a photograph whips
it into a painting he probably did seven
of them that day he's uh a genuine
master of his
craft we
would a copy of that we can hang it in
the office Brad so Rick can have the
original if he wants it's just FedEx get
to him is going to take months
apparently yes so that's what we have we
got one last photo um as part of this
kind of special but it's for you Rick
and we were trying to time it so FedEx
would actually give it to you at the
exact moment but unfortunately play the
video first yeah so we'll play the video
we'll play the video um Instead This is
where Mom comes in this is where Mom
comes in hi Rick I'm Laur Wright Brad
Wright's mother of course um and I just
want to say how much I enjoy the
companion and seeing you and the rest of
the co cast of Stark sg1 a marvelous
show I really enjoyed it and uh I just I
I did hear that you love dogs and I do
too I'm I'm I painted so many wonderful
dogs and I I did one for you
too oh
no me the picture your beautiful
dog and uh I I hope you like it too
oh
mama that's
gorgeous isn't it good oh
M
Laura Lura Lura Lura Lura oh wonderful
look at her yeah it's all about the eyes
we we had this conversation and she
always captures the eyes God she's um
she's really proud of this one she my
mom is 91 next next
week and you Foy oh I'm I'm what's
what's the word for it um flabbergast
um is it smack is good yeah oh that's
cor I need her phone number you know
that right yeah yeah and you'll get
it
yeah it's uh it's I I was It was
supposed to come yesterday to your house
and and FedEx screwed up so uh you'll
get it tomorrow supposed to come last
week to your host but in a way I'm glad
because this is you would have opened it
and this is your genuine reaction I
think Mom's gonna like no kidding it's
so great
H Laura I love
you I really uh she's proud of it too
she did uh Buu do you remember buo she
did the painting of buo for me yeah that
is lovely and I showed you Tango and
when you remarked on on the job she did
Tango mom mom says to me and this is
this is you know she's so shy about her
work she says do you do you think Rick
would like it if I did a a picture of
his dog and I said I think you would
love it and you had just sent me a
lovely photograph M and so I sent it to
Mom and Saidi think you could do this
and she saidoh I know I can't I'll get
right on
it and and you know she would send me
updates and I kept saying it's it's
beautiful mom and um she chose the frame
and uh framed it and and I picked it up
last week and uh you should have it
tomorrow oh Bradley it's just wonderful
Absolut think
so hits me in my heart yeah
yeah and I knew it would
my thanks okay
bye
jeez well I you know I we we we don't
have to go on and on about it but I I'm
I'm proud of my mom very much and and
think she's uh and I'm even more proud
that she thought it would be a nice gift
for you for our 25th
anniversary and uh and I guess it is
just wonderful absolutely wonderful
thanks okay okay we're both getting a
little bit Clem here Lawrence we've been
we've been dicing the onions you know
and then so it's it's it's that uh but
no thank thank you both and I hope you
enjoyed we enjoyed the conversation and
and Rick I can't wait for you to get
that painting and um there was a
conversation that we're going to play
for the rest of the the fans it's about
10 minutes or so where um you and Amanda
and Michael and Brad
um spoke about uh a couple months ago
when we did the Stargate AI event uh we
talked about children of the Gods and
the kind of the early days in the
casting process so we're going to wrap
up with that so if there's anything else
either of you want to say um in terms of
goodbyes um let's do that now and then
we're gonna kind of just roll that
honestly I just I just want to say to
the fans watching this uh
um 25 years is a long time but it's it's
if you told me 25 years ago that the
show would still
be uh popular enough that it's its
anniversary was celebrated at all I
would I would be shocked and uh and to
be able to share that with my friend
Rick is uh it was fun and and uh I'm
just glad we're both here and happy to
do this
together that's all you need to say
buddy I I'm still lost in Ry
here um yeah it's it's been a nice run
um and it's nice like 25 years later I'm
I'm brought to Tears by this man who I
never would have
met and therefore never met her Mo his
mother um but that I mean that's what
Stargate did for me it brought me a
friend like Brad um and more his mother
it's be
on but uh but thank you every every man
Jack of
you um yeah thanks let's do it again
sometime
let's